so the question yeah I know when I got
you really yep do you it's hard to
remember your money I hate this because
if you don't remember then the other
person can [ __ ] trump you and just
not believe what they say there's no
reason why you'd remember when we've had
our first conversation there's zero
reason why you'd remember and I know and
I know this okay and you don't even know
when it was and it wasn't and both of us
were not doing stand-up yet really yep
and I've told you this and you forgot it
because of the same reason why when I
told you this was the same reason why
when we met is because you were high
both times
really that's awesome we were in we were
in a saddle ranch no were you doing
there you know what I don't know okay
yeah me neither yeah so so you the
people were riding the bull and you were
kind of like you were with some people
that had to do with some kind of
production I think it was that but you I
was not in line for the books I would
not ever ride the bull right we were all
around that area and I was like huh and
I looked at you and I was like crazy huh
or something
I don't know what I said but you said
and a lot of chicks out there out we're
in a world in the bowl hole yeah you see
all these girls huh something like that
yeah and you were so faded yeah like I'm
pills or something while you were on
pills this isn't a real thing or
something it was some ranch bro I
remember you had a hat on dude I
remember dude I remember when I met you
then no I didn't make it up yeah you
can't say then after that that's a real
story
I do remember all right I remember when
I met you so I remember I was playing
like a young okay athletic men's
basketball league right already this is
wrong
no all didn't used to live in your own
limbic this is off of Olympic Boulevard
now or was it couldn't it might have
been might have enough somewhere else
like a Wilshire or Senate or Santa
Monica Boulevard and um and it was like
it was a like a it was like a league I
was in as like a championship game or
whatever my team was our team was called
hot to try
right that was our team okay so anyway
when he's coming back to me now
yeah so anyway it's like the end of the
game I Drive get fouled score right it's
an obvious and one I'm gonna go to the
line and the ref row okay first of all
the [ __ ] crap dude all legs right
this is probably ten years going you're
a little bit younger okay all legs do
barely it was like legs and like long
hair you couldn't really know much else
about animal um he's like no foul that's
what he said blues whistling comes over
goes no foul it was you and he was on
pills
I don't refuse on pills but he
definitely didn't know anything about
refereeing I don't even know if he was
an actual referee but I just remember
him he [ __ ] ruined it Wow and I
discern a man for who the [ __ ] is that
guy how do you gain attention I don't I
tell you what there's a lot [ __ ] my life
I don't remember I don't remember that
but I will tell you this I stand by my
call yeah and I honestly think you
[ __ ] traveled to by my mom yeah I
think you probably traveled dude it was
for the west district city championship
bro and I was like and I think I
remember if I don't remember this but if
it did happen I think I remember
thinking dude I wonder if you [ __ ]
paid for a plane ticket with that travel
oh yeah yeah well like I got a shower
from kayak yeah yeah I remember the guys
had a really bad joke like that
were you on pricing calm or whatever the
[ __ ] and you go whoa and I saw on your
face in the middle of the war you got
the joke but yeah I definitely remember
that man or so do you remember a meeting
I don't remember the first time we met
comedy wise though stand up beside
outside of the saddle ranch or the
basketball rec league yeah I don't
remember I mean I remember one night
there was some girl I assume that got
mad at you on the front porch of the
comments remember that and I remember
like she was just being like a real
[ __ ] and I remember I don't remember
that
the only other times of it that I even I
don't even remember talking you that
much until maybe about like two years
ago
you know hmm I never liked talking to
people that were doing well in comedy
yeah I know you're [ __ ] weird like
that bro well because I don't like them
I never wanna I don't know so many
people that seem like we're like yeah I
understand that but you're so not that
guy yeah but if you do that kind of
behavior then I've like you become that
goes long as you're aware of that then
you're not gonna be that guy right you
know it's not like you're [ __ ] you
know it's not like you're like the guy
that's like these [ __ ] guys around
you know as it just stand yeah you're
like what what are you doing model
standing yeah but you like in the
parking lot of the Comedy Store you're
talking and you're like what's but
what's [ __ ] going here oh there's a
guy right here oh yeah those guys yeah
we're like you're like am i in a horror
movie what the [ __ ] is happening you
yeah and there's just a [ __ ] scene
never where and if I was ever a stander
dude and [ __ ] dude get out of here
there's loiter at least pace yeah a
hundred percent and if you're just gonna
stand say some [ __ ] yeah those guys got
to go go to lunch those guys are [ __ ]
out to lunch right yeah this one I would
press one of your buttons right now but
I'm using this right good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one